employees at this fuel station in
Georgia say they're thankful they
weren't at work when this area flooded
at the end of July
owner jojen says the water was almost
three meters deep turning the back of
the station into a Dumping Ground and
rendering most of his fuel supplies
useless
right now the total damage is around two
hundred thousand dollars but that's just
my initial estimate because there must
be more damage underground that I
haven't seen yet
Chinese authorities are also discovering
typhoon doxury caused more destruction
than originally thought two weeks after
the storm struck the emergency response
has been upgraded to its highest level
dozens of people were killed and several
are still missing in Herve Province
direct economic losses are estimated at
more than 13 billion dollars evacuation
orders were issued for 1.6 million
people many returned to find their homes
had collapsed clean up in the main
streets of Giorgio is well underway but
turn a corner into a small village like
this one and it's hardly begun parts of
this community are still underwater it's
very difficult for cars and emergency
teams to enter
officials say areas like this could
remain submerged for up to a month
people here tell us the authorities
likely miscalculated the scale of the
storm and failed to give residents
adequate warning
things were good before we were all
doing well then this flood suddenly came
my heart is broken it's all gone
private and non-profit organizations
have set up donation points for those in
need each family is given a small amount
but most are harping they'll eventually
receive enough government compensation
to start over until then they say all
they can do is pick up the pieces and
wait Katrina Al Jazeera tortrow China